E
SPIRIT >> Sean: I GUESS HE IS
GOING TO GO THERE
TO CHEER THEM ON.
HERE NOW WITH REACTION, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR LAW
PROFESSOR JONATHAN TURLEY IS
WITH US.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE, FROM THE
LEGAL PERSPECTIVE THAT THE
ANALYSIS WE ARE GETTING IS
ACCURATE.
THERE IS AN ENUMERATED RIGHT TO
KEEP AND BEAR ARMS.
THAT WOULD JUSTIFY YESTERDAY'S
DECISION ON THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
THERE IS NO ENUMERATED RIGHT
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
CONSTITUTION BUT OUR FRAMERS AND
THEIR WISDOM ANTICIPATED SUCH
CONFLICT AND MOMENT AND HENCE WE
HAVE THE TENTH AMENDMENT INTO A
CERTAIN EXTENT I WOULD ARGUE THE
NINTH AMENDMENT THAT SENDS
ISSUES LIKE THIS BACK TO THE
STATE, WHICH SEEMS APPROPRIATE
IN THIS CASE WHICH IS WHY I'VE
ALWAYS FELT THAT ROE IS A BAD
LAW YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> THIS IS PART OF WHAT THE
COURT WAS GRAPPLING WITH.
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT ROE V. WADE AS
IF IT IS AN INVIOLATE DECISION.
IN FACT, ROE V. WADE ITSELF
WASN'T GUTTED.
THE PRIVACY BASED ANALYSIS THAT
CAME OUT OF THE 1973 OPINION WAS
LATER REMOVED IN KC AND THERE
WAS A SUBSTITUTE WHICH GAVE US
THE UNDUE BURDEN STANDARD.
ROE WAS CRIMINALIZED BY MANY
LIBERAL ACADEMICS.
PEOPLE LIKE LAURENCE TRIBE
CALLED IT A SMOKE SCREEN.
AS YOU SAW, GINSBURG HERSELF
SAID IT WENT TOO FAR.
THIS WASN'T A DECISION THAT WAS
WIDELY ACCEPTED IN TERMS OF ITS
ANALYSIS.
BUT THERE ARE ARGUMENTS THAT
COULD BE MADE UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION FOR THIS PRIVACY OR
EQUAL PROTECTION OR DUE PROCESS
RIGHT BUT THE COURT CLEARLY
DIDN'T SEE THAT IN THEIR
ARGUMENT IS NOT THAT ABORTION
SHOULD BE UNLAWFUL.
THEY ARE NOT SAYING ANYTHING
ABOUT WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN TO
ABORTION.
THEY ARE SEEING MORE OF WHO
SHOULD MAKE THAT DECISION AND
THEY SAID IN THE OPINION THAT IN
1973 THEY ESSENTIALLY STOPPED A
POLITICAL DEBATE THAT WAS GOING
ON IN THE COUNTRY.
AND WHAT THEY SAID TODAY WAS,
HAVE AT IT.
HAVE THAT DEBATE.
HAVE 33, 330 BILLION AMERICANS
MAKE THE DECISION RATHER THAN
NINE JUSTICES.
WE WERE GOING TO SEE VARIATIONS
AMONG THE KEY STATES.
MOST TO PROTECT THE RIGHT TO
ABORTION.
IN 1973, 30 STATES WHEN IT WAS
HANDED DOWN PROHIBITED ABORTION
BY ALL EXCEPT IN THE MOST
LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES, BUT THE
COUNTRY HAS MOVED ON THIS ISSUE.
BUT NOW THE ISSUE HAS MOVED BACK
AND IT WILL BE DECIDED
STATE-BY-STATE.
>> Sean: KNOWING THE CURRENT
MAKEUP OF NEW YORK AND
NEW JERSEY AND ILLINOIS AND
CALIFORNIA, AND EVEN KNOWING FOR
EXAMPLE MISSISSIPPI, WHICH
BROUGHT THIS BEFORE THE
SUPREME COURT, THEY JUST HAD A
REGULATION, STATE REGULATION OF
15 WEEKS.
IS THAT A FAIR STATEMENT?
>> YES, IN FACT THE MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY ARE
VIRTUALLY GUARANTEED TO LIVE IN
A STATE WHERE ABORTION IS NOT
GOING TO BE UNLAWFUL.
STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA AND
NEW YORK, ILLINOIS THAT ARE
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO REMAIN A
ROBUSTLY PROTECTIVE STATES AND
EVEN STATES WITH REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS LIKE VIRGINIA TODAY.
SENATOR YOUNG CAN SET I WOULD
LIKE TO PURSUE A
MISSISSIPPI-LIKE RULE AND HE
SAYS, I'M ALSO WILLING TO
COMPROMISE.
LET'S TALK, LET'S SEE WHAT A
REASONABLE COMPROMISE IS.
THAT IS PART OF THE VISION THE
FRAMERS HAD FOR THE FEDERALISM
MODEL, 60 STATES WORKING ON
PROBLEMS, THERE'S A CHANCE YOU
CAN COME UP WITH CREATIVE
COMPROMISES.
OUT OF ALL OF THAT
EXPERIMENTATION, CAN BECOME A
RESOLUTION.
I THINK WHAT YOU WERE GOING TO
SEE IS A NUMBER OF STATES IN THE
SHORT-TERM THAT ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON THESE TRIGGER LAWS, THAT
ARE GOING TO BAN ABORTION EXCEPT
EXCEPT IN VERY LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES.
BUT IN THE MAJORITY, FOR THE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY, THE POST ROE WORLD WILL
NOT BE DRAMATICALLY DIFFERENT
FROM THE ROE WORLD IN THE SENSE
THAT THEY ARE LIVING IN STATES
WHERE THAT RIGHT WILL BE
PROTECTED.
>> Sean: LET ME PLAY FOR YOU
CHUCK SCHUMER ON THE STEPS OF
THE SUPREME COURT AND I WANT TO
GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS.
>> I WANT TO TELL YOU, GORE SELL
JUSTICE GORSUCH AND KAVANAUGH,
YOU HAVE
RELEASED THE WHIRLWIND AND HE
WILL PAY THE PRICE!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
YOU WILL KNOW WHAT HIT YOU IF
YOU GO FORWARD WITH THESE AWFUL
DECISIONS!
>> Sean: YOU RELEASE TO THE
WHIRLWIND, YOU WILL PAY THE
PRICE, YOU WON'T KNOW WHAT HIT
YOU.
YOU ARE A GREAT LAWYER, IF THAT
WAS ME THE STEPS OF THE
SUPREME COURT, WHY DO I THINK
THERE WOULD BE CONSEQUENCES THAT
I WOULD HAVE TO FACE AS A RESULT
OF SAYING SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
AND I DON'T THINK YOU CAN GET ME
OUT OF IT.
>> THAT WAS ONE OF THE LOWEST
POINTS THAT I HAVE WITNESSED IN
MY LIFETIME, IN TERMS OF THE
SUPREME COURT AND HOW IT IS
BEING TREATED.
THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
MAKING THREATS, CALLING OUT TWO
JUSTICES BY NAME REALLY SHOCKS
ALL OF US.
THIS IS AN AGE OF RAGE, I DON'T
THINK HE WAS CALLING FOR
VIOLENCE BUT WHAT HE WAS DOING
WAS RECKLESS AND PEOPLE HEAR
THOSE TYPES OF WORDS AND
THEY TAKE A MUCH DIFFERENT
MEANING, WE SAW VERY VIOLENT
MEANING.
WE SAW THAT IN FRONT OF JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH'S HOUSE AND TODAY WE
ARE SEEING THE SAME FAILURE OF
LEADERSHIP AS POLITICIANS GO OUT
AND SAY THINGS THAT ARE NOT
TRUE.
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS AND
SPEAKER PELOSI TALKING ABOUT HOW
THIS DECISION ENDANGERS THINGS
LIKE MULTIRACIAL OR INTERRACIAL
MARRIAGES AND CONTRACEPTIVE
PROTECTION.
THE COURT WENT TO AN
EXTRAORDINARY DEGREE TO SWAT
DOWN THOSE ARGUMENTS.
I HAVEN'T SEEN AN OPINION WHERE
THE COURT REPEATEDLY RETURNS TO
THIS ISSUE AND SAY THIS IS NOT
GOING TO ENDANGER THOSE RIGHTS.
IT KEEPS ON COMING BACK AND
SAYING, WE ARE GOING TO EXTEND
THIS POSITION TO THINGS LIKE
MARRIAGE OR CONTRACEPTION IS
SIMPLY UNTRUE.
THEY WERE
THERE WAS ONLY ONE JUSTICEWHO SO
RE-EXAMINE THIS OCCASION FOR THE
FIVE OTHER JUDGES EXPRESSLY SAID
THAT IS NOT GOING TO BE THE
CASE.
YET THAT IS BEING IGNORED.
ONE LAW PROFESSOR RESPONDED TO
ME AND SAID WE DON'T BELIEVE
ANYTHING THEY SAY ANYWAY.
THEN WHAT IS THE POINT OF LEGAL
ANALYSIS IF YOU ARE JUST GOING
TO SAY THAT EVERYTHING IS A
LIVE?
THAT CERTAINLY MAKES OUR TASK
RATHER EASY.
BUT IT IS NOT A LIE.
THESE JUSTICES DREW VERY CLEAR
LINE.
ABORTION IN THEIR VIEW IS UNIQUE
IN THI